who nor evening wherever you are and
welcome to android developers office
hours this is your chance to come and
ask us the Android developer relations
team and we've also guests from the
google TV develop relations team any
questions you like about developing
android applications we as usual won't
be covering any product announcements or
speculating on any future releases so
don't waste your time answering that
asking those questions but and do ask us
any and all android developer questions
so who do we have here we have i'm
joined on the left by rich Hyndman okay
and not gone and in the room we have al
Sutton as always hey guys oh and is that
tile down then the right hello hey
Android Andrew Kelly one my mother s
machine yeah it looks like London of
dropped out on us a little bit welcome
back on well that bodes well for the
rest of this I just trying to work the
chat window and welcome Andrew Kelly oh
yeah we have from okay if you're in a
feedback it seems to be musically so
news well while we wait for a few people
to join us was one uses their Google
Play services has finally launched its
no longer next week as we've been saying
for a while so there we had chance to
check that out yet not yet no well yeah
I mean I read the blog post does that
kind of shaky I'm really looking forward
to write my first place services based
application using the oauth2 being a
blog into the services
that's one button and of course that's
going to affect the plus one of your
application in the Play Store and that
might affect your ranking no let's see
+1 buttons inside out but there's also
many other things inside yeah we are
recently a hackathon we're lost people
trying to access google drive and it's
like painful tryna get and have to use
the web for you to get your non
anonymous I guess then scoped oh off to
token so you can now do that really
easily with a really consistent user
experience through figure facility so
yeah looking forward to seeing some apps
integrate those it's the Play services
library going to be supported on google
TV as well I believe it will be but that
will probably come with the native
google play store which is coming I mean
next week next week everything
everything happens next week man yo man
cool is that Chris Bane's we had just
pop in hey guys oh hang on timing
someone faded up telling you on a
hangout oh yeah I'm over yes you had a
busy day dinner so you updated a bunch
of your libraries yeah just um I took
them all September off so I mean messing
around the whole September and say yes
sir thanks oh yeah that fun do some
housekeeping nice setting stuff fun yes
good ok your question from Andrew inside
the Chapman already yeah does google
play services allow posting to google+
or is it an api still coming to and
still coming to UM as far as I'm aware
google+ allows you to post something to
someone's timeline but it's it's
essentially you're posting it to no one
it's not public or anything and then you
have to select the circle like the user
has to go into Google for us to do it
they've known anything that's Google
Play services that's just Google piece
so you don't matter history API yeah so
it's essentially if it like how instant
upload works you can send stuff to
somewhere which is just owned by you and
then from there easily share it later on
if you want but
I attending at all I've been running out
here no one its cheddar because it's
definitely mentioned in the Play
services documentation I think it's
coming slowly history okay so the only
sharing his father +1 button my garden
and spars on whether history API still a
developer preview so they're still tying
that down so it's not worth using in
production apps and told things are
stabilized a bit i'd guess yeah i would
guess as well the patient says might
similar but still it's great it's
getting rolled out total devices are you
love and um mute what else has happened
this week then we're talking about
tablets this week this week is tablet
week on for all the shows on the android
developer network cream in there a
developer stoking woke up for such life
forward slash android so retail and ian
and the guise of america will be with
other than iniquity redesigned and we
dime stiffly making a point of using the
web tablet in this show so we can feel
included in the mountain view program as
well i'm holding a tablet tablet but
you're wondered what that was and I
hopefully the audio quality is improved
this week we've got a brand new
microphone previously I'm not
comfortable how they should with the
audio quality doesn't let us know and
we'll try and fix it this this puppy
that we've got here I kind of want to
show you so before we dive into
moderator key does anyone have any
questions now or anything you want to
talk about it's not cut man cool
moderator it is and oh yeah we should
also explain Sparky's not here is a
public holiday in Germany apparently not
tied to the oktoberfest apparently not
in my way no definitely not yeah he's
not outside next week oh I don't
remember it was tied to banning mall
couldn't it wasn't it is it the wall
coming down I think how is it ah ok onto
the moderator get rich hello hi hey
Andre from Germany I'll be watching us
holiday I once you set preferred network
type method to switch between 2g and 3G
apparently however available to public
I'm guessing it's as a party however
it's not available to the public is
there alternatives network how I
personally don't think so I've looked
into this before for the battery widget
people have asked how do you switch to
2g and once we were in an airport maybe
in the Czech Republic somewhere I wanted
to limit our danger we were writing like
that to toggle between 2g and 3G to save
battery life at the time we couple years
ago and we didn't find a way without
just sending the user to the network
setting screens there's no public
lighting is a surgical center thank you
to everyone who just me to the same time
so thank you wonder it but I think not
see ya at some of these in secure is it
secure city was it is hidden I think
it's secure safe yeah it's Ellen not
their own yeah so unless your signature
system and so unless you kind of had
access to the plat funky and so unless
you're thought you and romney budget yep
next ah my app this is from a teacher
from fairfax virginia hey my app is a
feature where users can upload documents
or pictures when i try accessing
attachments in emails that are not
downloaded the uri object has the scheme
of content is there a way to convert
this your object to it has a scheme of
file
you would almost certainly need to go to
the content provider that that schema
content is pointing to and try and get
it from the content provider we have a
post on this for getting picasa images
from the gallery so if you do the image
to chooser and gallery comes up and
instead of choosing the photograph at
the table on the camera they choose a
photograph that was in picasa again you
get the content URI and you need to go
to the concert result so you won't be
able to resolve it to a file directly
but you'll be able to get all the
content through its respective provider
yeah basically squadron provider get a
file descriptor that game in which you
can then do it stuff on so I have a look
at that in search for retrieving
pocasset images from gallery as well
because there's definitely a a more
detailed post with the details of how to
Don that and they will come up with
comes in your eyes we get that quite a
lot from companies that have photo
editing applications things like that
they don't expect selected images to
come back as a content URI they've been
filed it's one of those things that you
look for in an application as well as
its ability to read all kinds of content
shared to it's over one eye off and find
people flowing foul love is when you try
and attach a photo or upload a photo and
it's coming from a casa gallery rather
than you know a local image and so yeah
it's really really is good practice to
be able to handle every single content
Oh every form of uri you get cross back
looks on tablets tablets don't and it
wasn't sounds good keeps on a bomber
we've got one question of here in the G+
asking when cool devices will be
available in Ukraine and as per the
announcement of the start of the show we
probably have a lot more viewers if we
could talk about that kind of a small
chat and sidebar going on about TG Fuji
as new yeah we can't talk about
potential patterns I don't know any
anyway ah ah Christian ok I just
chatting about themselves it's generally
like the discussions going Rio basically
saying someone really wants to be able
to control 2g 3G setting to save battery
I kind of think that's the domain of
like the users choice like the user can
choose that and they can set that
various settings and it's one thing if
you
want to give a little hint and saying
you know if your apps related to the
battery sorry maybe you go showing
battery their horse and have a link out
to take you to the page where you can
and change a setting that's one thing
that you probably don't to be going and
even if you could just change the
setting under them because that's kind
of well depends what your address but it
sounds like it might be an unexpected
behavior they have do your battery's
running low would you like to go to know
besides I know a good battery widget
that an mg theme v that religion the
veteran need to redesign what's on
tablets like how do I animate on the
expanding collapse event of an
expandable list of you I would look at
the API for expandable list view and see
huge diaper IV animation event usually
it's on the UM I'm no that's it no I'm
over dinner would anyone use expendable
its key I have I'll never change the
animation credit nice of time the
animation tends to be although the
default animation tends to be quite
quick and probably would annoy users to
slow that down any amount because it's
nice once or twice to see a fancy
animation that's always good make sure
you get the data to the user as quickly
as possible maybe the one second yeah
expanding is just emboss no scrolling so
you can't change it okay no Sasuke
so again so your options are to make
create your own I guess you could turn
yeah subclass it and if you want to do
your own behavior they're not really way
to go den you go towards special really
what do you think about a nice thank you
really want to do let's have a look back
on the thread so a few more new joiners
oh hello to Paul and Paul and Richard
you've joined us and house you got Neil
so yeah feel free to give ask questions
here or type in cycle or anything hi
guys um are you gonna send me a stack
overflow link for your energy question
yes I put them up Apple II didn't send
it I fell at your name is Nick butcher
I've sent one cell just as
I see he said he might have a look at
the service and say there's a way of
getting to the time out another way yeah
I did double check the stock over I
think I put a link on this comment here
but anyway if you want me to send again
I can find you out on G+ do that there
yeah I'm good the main thing is just
wondering if anyone's got any ideas
alternative is to do a build so we can
demo this and where we might be able to
find it the sauce because I've quit
looking the sauce around all the NSE
stuff but i don't think the constants
are in the java so i wonder if there's a
resource file or some exploding from any
ideas there's a class just really of the
tag class in android NFC has a get
tagged get tech list method and you can
get a list of technologies that support
it by the RFC reader from that and pass
that to the get method to actually get
an instance of the NFC class for that
particular type of tag yep you can then
use the manipulation methods on that tag
instance so set timeout on that to alter
the timeout for that specific type of
technology tag okay just to explain I
that works in Gingerbread because you
can set it because you get access the
program's launch far enough for the code
to be run in the cases of ice cream
sandwich and a later the sound goes on
the phone like you I it doesn't even
reach the breakpoints or that or the
code of that state so I wonder if
there's a how to change the default
timeout so that it gets it allows it to
get further because in some cases I
believe it's point 30 seconds the I'm
just looking it now in the Android NFC
tech package there's an iso dep class
which has the get method which can get
you an instance of that tank class
without actually using the RF radio okay
let me just pop up a link to it in the
chat sidebar yeah great and that you can
manipulate the set timeout
on that the tank that's returned from
that method and from looking into the
code there is a lot of source code in
the framework based but there's also
some in packages apps NFC and there's a
lot of the management code in there from
looking at that unless you call close on
that tag object you returned by the get
method in the ISO depth class the
timeout should stay all the time you're
reading tags of that class yes i believe
the closing would reset the timeout and
i did one quick test of aesthetic tag
that i'd set the timeout longer to see
if that worked i just gave me an hour to
sir long shot i didn't seem to work at
that moment but willing to try again I
looks a bit deeper into it okay i'll put
the links to the methods into the
comment section of this hangout yes you
can grab them from there thank you thank
you very much Cheers excellent thanks
out no worries ah the next mon rates
question Oh Andrew Kelly's bubble in the
chat first anjel asks what is the style
attribute I need to change to alter the
text color for options menu option menu
items I've managed to change the title
color but couldn't see the option menu
style this is an action bar yes oh you
wanna have a look at a post written by
yeah I never remembered his offhand but
there's a handy post hopefully if you
seen the post I wrote on the Android
developers blog if you ask yes he says
and the looked in the attached were the
links and co project so if you look in
the in the Styles file in the indigo
project there they should give you the
attribute need to arrive so I forget it
you've ever ignore everything else but
not the actual text what text color
although alright so change it okay so
it's it's I forget it offhand did you
try android coral text color
the way I write live the way I worked
out which one's a change I always end up
just looking in the original fumes file
so if you look in your Android home /
platforms / what a platform / data value
there's the styles and themes to xml
just they're not particularly long and
then you know if you're not too scared
way XML at a fairly readable so you go
in there and you kind of search for like
action bar options and stuff like that
and and and you can walk it back upwards
and find out which start in Herricks
from and you find that kind of the
valley you can override that's the way I
always end up doing it so sorry I don't
know offhand but it may not be
separately styled to the actual text on
the action bar be interesting to see if
there is it's probably never even by
default one hand it might be sound like
color or text car they might be worth
trying hmm there we go cheers andrew do
you not have a microphone and ray you
can go you too shy okay silence oh yeah
simony from pittsburgh has quite a poor
reaching question which we could do if
you come to online ready to talk about
because the question is i have an app
idea how do i create it he's one app
from beginning to finish hmm right so I
guess I you a coder are you looking for
people to contract work for you who are
you I mean are you a designer I don't
really know which parts of the role you
can fill in yourself but um well you
just want to make money from the idea
you could license it to someone without
actually building anything yeah it's
quite a wide-reaching question it's
almost the same yeah if you are just you
know if you know a bit of code IAM
indefinitely android before it's a great
place to start is an Android training to
go to developer.android.com / training
there's some basic guys there which took
you through how to create your first
android app so it kind of seems a
certain level of knowledge of java and
xml and so on so if you have those then
that's good place to start beyond that I
guess week I need a bit more please just
got an idea I would start with a piece
of paper and a pencil and start
sketching out and stop
thinking about how you want the actual
application to work and flow and get
excited about their concepts behind it
and then you could go to a user brief in
whatever technology you want it to be
delivered in and have a talk that to
some people these are about it each
other's plenty in Pittsburgh aah yeah
there's there's a lot of approach to
take stemming from it step three profit
use tablets do an extra large layout
good okay Jeff rich perfect radio Farage
because it's one of those questions we
can't answer will all developers on
Google Play have reply to reviews so
sorry some things that I'm already
announced oh dear one in the room being
using had access to reply to reviews in
any better yes no you have for ya then
I've replied to console that region also
have and there's been been getting if
you see this is in your rating no not
particularly but my latest version I've
got this really weird bug on a sony
xperia phone on Ice Cream Sandwich for
the widget and I can't replicate it so
hey I've got access to a lot of places I
think they just found which fun uh some
sony ericsson p19 I something and then
also on then what would divide and
peeling only have done this thing
existed until some reporting a bug on it
I believe it's quarter vga and in
landscape mode the widgets or if it's
freaky who knows but all that mr. very
good solution to a challenge oh thank
you very much for your feedback you can
no longer use the application as a good
reply ok so I'm so much person yeah so
Nick your mocs in design in action on
Tuesdays were very impressive especially
the tiger hunt this deer tripadvisor
you're not a designer at risk layman
what's your secret have you read any
books or resources and
give up to speed with interaction design
of the designs that you've done ah how
did you get into this because owe me a
year ago you might designing stuff as
part of the team and now you're the
go-to designer nothing yeah how'd it
happen I think you just fake it to make
it right you just said no I don't know I
always been really interested in UI
design and I think I'm pretty like okay
quite attention to detail but quicker
focus on detail like that i always
notice really small things are wrong and
i think that probably helps when you're
designing stuff so keep on going over
know you only see how long i spent all
these months go over and over and over
them again until till they get better
and i'll only there's any secret i think
i read a lot on subject so blogs like
you ha nice blog and Android UI design
smashing magazine oh I'm a big fan of
read a lot of articles on that and
practice I think and the more you do it
the better and easier it gets so simple
things like learning your tooling like
Photoshop has been a quite a full metal
from you haven't used it much reduced
GIMP effect when I used to create apps
used to create all my own assets in the
GIMP got a fairly proficient of that but
then relearning Photoshop because that
seems to be what everyone around here
uses and so you can share this DS and so
on that that's really handy has taken me
a while and but I think with the big
spirits help me is working with a newer
designer so there's a UI team here and
drop them in London he a similar design
for the google apps such as Google now
site here in London and so that team has
been also they being really
accommodating to me so I've gone in
there and booked them as it like showing
them sketches and talk them through and
show the marks and got feedback and
going around around that that kind of
like feedback loop it's been super
helpful to me so no secret just a lot of
work really and so yeah I wouldn't call
myself designer yet but I'm I'm trying
to like look like one I guess so view 40
those designs to try not to revise my
stuff or is what what's or the angle
back on side uh the goal is just to kind
of like increase awareness of fighting
it's one thing to talk about what
Android design is and but we think it's
it's better to show it like I think that
before and after format is really useful
it's not so much the goal to have the
company take these mocks and implement
them or
you know incorporate some of the
elements I mean that's amazing but
that's a bonus it's more to have like a
practical insight into what everyone in
their apps can do and like you know how
to look at a certain type of problem and
how it might be solved in a more
adroitly kind of way so if the
tripadvisor one and my colleague Adam in
New York actually works at tripadvisor
he said he's going to send them to them
say more than welcome in fact them
bloomer the week beforehand we we did
them the redesign of that else in social
development sent him the PSD so he says
he's gonna use it yeah well develop a
strike back we often say they're going
to take a lot of the feedback on for
music design wise and best practices
wise with me yes sir yes if the camera
team Alex it heals net incorporate
civilians excellent service if you
wanted off the chosen get floated off on
the moderate to get you a pre-designed I
know playing from here that they don't
like the design of it basically granting
immunity yeah as long as you implemented
well as long as I've everyone's story
true story and drinking again on the
action bar thieving have you look to
just read theming the action drop-down
style from the hollow of the 10 line the
you ever write on a light and then you
extend you wanna write and live like the
drop-down style and then change the text
car it's like that if you look at as if
you're trying to change the text color
Germany the text goes generally
determined on it whether ill and
inheriting from a dark light style so
obviously the dog star as light Texan
lifestyle has dog text and so if you're
trying to change the colors of the
action but make sure you inheriting from
the correct parent so you might even if
you have a light theme you might want to
inherit from the theme that holo that
light dark action bar if you have a like
a darker accent color to your action bar
and that'll give you the right text
color so I'm just wondering if there's a
bigger problem if where we know
inheriting for the right my parents are
but response does say he's put in
android text appearance followed up we
did a pop-up don't know you have small a
fitness
what the actual style isn't lot platform
I don't know worry where that's found
from Bob spanning the source so just
backtrack and try and find that where
that was in the theme other day I was
like it's been one of those yeah and
risa which is the parent theme you're
inheriting from so you're not inheriting
from holo light so you there for getting
a dark textile by default and what's the
color and what's the color of the but i
guess the options may be that you your
try and make the tech show up against
yellow well the custom graphic
background she's dark passion bother
that's was going to say it Harriet from
theme the hollow or finish up like got
dark action bar will give you like text
good easier okay okay any more question
is from inside the Chung inside the hang
up before I jump to the next one hello
you to a few new joiners as well who we
got here Richard Thompson is trying to
come back and Xavi I think that is with
a fun little profile photo hello to you
guys feel free to shout out or type away
if you've got questions live or you can
just chill out and enjoy the show might
be worth putting in a plug for the new
build system that the guys over a
mountain view have made available yeah
goes haven't taught I'm already really
is anyone else listen to you I've
started looking at if it's placed on is
it Gradle that's low I've got to get
everything set up to you to an idea nope
it's very bare-bones at the moment
selling got lint hasn't got proguard
stuff like that but it hasn't got any k
yep so it's it's basically the start of
it but it's a case of the earlier you
get in the more likely you are to get
the features you want so if anyone's
really interesting the build system
where has been hitting their head have a
look at the adt dev google group and
they'll be details on how to get more
information ok richard thompson just put
in the chat window
how'd you find designers uh there isn't
an easily accessible repository of
designers that I know about Joe era yes
I say chuckles as usual with freebies
that is is a Bezier social network for
designers and they has quite a big focus
on jobs oh yeah took your things put
there are plenty of great design
companies around I bump into them at
various meet up to put them in London or
down in Brighton things like that so
going to meet up to talk to people I'm
look at apps that you like the way they
were designed so if you can find your
designer have a bigger package name with
an application that you like that above
and work out who really made it when
what a bar and Tim bugs or who I think
are the wider range in question how do
you make it HAP has chimed in in the
comments the gbus he says he needs to
write a simple app it just does some
maths but nice to have a good UI is he's
been watching the design hangouts good
man so question is any tips on who to
get quotes where to get it written and
he knows some simple code and but all
taking too long to learn java so he's
not going to himself all right so how do
you well it sounds like you if you win
to pay for the application like if it's
gonna be a commercial affair then you
might want to approach something like it
depends what your base but here in
London there's an awesome music group
called then the London android usergroup
or Android for short so that's a great
pool of talented developers and they
have a linkedin group which they like to
use for the job approaches and so you
could approach those pies after some
quotes ask for see who's around and what
they can offer and I don't know if it's
not a paid app if you're try and like
just doing it for fun or for charity or
something like that then I might not
work anyway oh yeah she said the fewer
offered land Reuters meetup.com /
android because they like their early
any of motive no I think that makes a
lot of sense getting a good mix of
people working for agencies freelancers
yeah I think lemon wrote a good place
any if this app inventor still do not
get donated to Apache is not Lisa photos
can you last take our pattern say again
the University wasn't it
then you might see got it yeah hose MIT
31 yes there was a project good and yeah
App Inventor which probably gotten a
don't know if it still usable water so
kind of a drag and drop type interface
for building an application to have to
pursue that to try get a prototype up
and running and show people around to
try and generate some interest and yeah
that's nothing actually is it often if
you're trying to get people on board
often quite helpful tablet and
interactive kind of like prototype so
you can even do that with something like
app inventor or if you use something
like fell stomach which is a mocking
tool you can design your mocs in that
and there's often there's a type
applications if you'll understand those
mops and how to make them together or
you can have an interactive PDF we have
like certain areas a hot where you click
prune it basically launch that never PDF
oh no a screen in the PDF so you think I
Adobe those with the tools / yeah poor
get from tobia in Italy this is a good
question i'd like to have a good answer
to this question maybe i'll work on it
to obtain a heterogeneous gridview like
the one in Google+ or Pinterest or I am
which was reviewed last week on the
android show should we extend abs sister
you adapt to your group you are there
any tutorials available I've been really
impressed with some of the area's great
views we've been seeing coming out
recently and I've often looked them I
wanted quite how they did it how they're
doing the layout of all the different
grid items and so um is not an answer I
was looking for it so you think yeah I
thought well it's all my gridview I've
been all very neat and tidy and aligned
and I haven't done anything which am as
yet looks as good as any of the Greek
music singer here I don't know where
must be Mustang I think they're just
going to be customer self here ah rows
of custom items it's not too difficult
to do it it's nitin know how how do I
out in standard sizing works oh so it's
not too bad today here this is you still
won't based on an adapter view if
possible and you want to have
asynchronous loading into the thing
obviously once you've got
allow that looks good you still gonna
want it to react very smoothly and
there's a lot of that code that we've
built for you all ready for things like
grid view the list views that you should
review really sorry so whether you can
have use a grid view and force it into
being a genius I don't think you can it
has to be many of these great to use it
be horrible I think use the column size
10 you yeah but that offense the column
size of the next row down as well you
can't do it on a column or row basis
right I wonder if some of these are
actually individual it's just a list
view and each sometimes the list item is
so int well not all the others for you
because everything's at least the same
height on a per row basis plus this
stuff in the list view where you can say
I've got views and multiple types and
then when you recycle it with try and
recycle the veals name types and then is
performace yeah depending on which way
do I would see if you can squeeze it
into a list view and just do a custom
list items inside a list to you it'll be
the simplest way you and you have a lot
of control over it and you'll get all
the benefits of so no one solve this
problem yet is an open source pet genius
this fuel grit fuel I can hear crest
typing as we speak into the code
respecting this glasses yeah it sounds
like a problem here I just saw one it
wouldn't be totally happy just to again
yeah if you did it go down the route of
writing your own custom widget as well
there's a great talk from dev ox two
years ago I think from a monkey and
share hostage-takers they go over the
basics of it what Chris was talking
about the layout artist measuring passes
it's really really critical to
understand those ones and especially if
it's done which ones happen often so it
need to be super efficient and not not
creating any garbage and so I advise you
to seek that out if you go to parlay
supcom is that where all the DevOps
talks or just google devops romani
creating custom widgets probably Gator I
might have to build one maybe this off
to me I'll mopping up in Photoshop you
might wanna build up this is 50 what is
how it should be
um anyone else got anything in the chat
all right sorry inside the Hangout for
Johnson hi guys can ask a further
question please last week Nick he said
that there was a I just missed a talk by
sonic Google an NFC Wiz guy is it
someone I can get in touch with all or
who it was you were referring to I at
this time last week because the talk i
just i think i was saying send me the
link to your question and i'll forward
it on to the NSE giri's it okay I'll put
it on I've put it on your I found you on
google plus I put on there because I'm
I'm doing a lot research in this area at
the moment so it would be handy to kind
of follow up a few more things in more
detail thank you very much guys have
loving the show today oh yes thanks for
asking good questions have you seen the
latest question we've got in the
crossbows no I haven't I'm throw mayhem
I'll good friend Michael Mann off x go
go Zuba ah travel advice / hi guys
design question for you what do you
think about to drop down lists on the
auction block action bar both forces at
work together imagine if you had a
second filter for each data so I'm
guessing this is a related to Michael's
player FM is it they're passing at hmm
booking website web app if you're making
um yes i can think of situations in fact
i think gallery initially when gallery
came out on honeycomb it had to drop
counts you can spin between photos and
videos and then sort between something
else problems down the road yeah but i
think they removed it you see if i can't
think of any there are quite a few which
have and I filters at the top um just
trying to figure out this traveling the
one that I could point to right now
apply to the program yeah all that name
feel free to tell us amox if you want
and if you've got any sketches what it's
good at like Mike and
I probably try to avoid it like it
sounds quite it's quite hard to
understand a glance perhaps depends i
was implemented like how if if the two
sets are like not overlapping then it
might be simpler words if you know you
have to change one person it and it
alters what's in the second list for
example then it's going to be quite hard
for it to be glanceable and change what
you might call for sound like a you know
like a filters button which actually
reveals your subsequent control or
dialogue of me is in the chat here he is
hey they might oh it seems like he's
behind and catching up yes yeah yeah
thanks thanks to L actually for letting
me in here um yeah I mean basically it's
pretty similar sort of analogy to gmail
right because basically the idea is to
try to use it as a kind of download
manager so instead of having a download
manager that you could just filter on
sorry I most massively it going here
it's okay no it's okay perhaps we can
thank you friends with it but I'm yeah
it's basically that I so um you can see
download status in one filter which
would probably just be an icon and i'm
here in the other one of the labels tags
sort of thing so you thought about
following the gmail example so having
the gonna label a click button at the
bottom I think he's plug his headphones
in a no he can't hear us yeah Mike Mike
seeing that oh yeah okay that's not
really actually because I've got I've
got a constraint of having something
else a player at the bottom so trying to
keep it simpler hello the idea being
that you click a button which takes you
to a subsequent screen which lets you
then you know have a full screen pic of
what data you're trying displayed
yeah it's got crazy today three two one
could you even do that I are three boys
because this is the action bar so sorry
case against are having some massive I
seem to be having two massive audio
syncing yeah we don't know I owe nearly
that are you listening to this on
podcast I repeat it okay so i was just
saying is it possible to just have a
button which launches a full screen to
let you pick the slices of data t one of
you rather than having it all on screen
at once I mean that's gonna be a private
no um okay no it's just i think i can
get caring myself but ok this is where I
think it's just lovely podcast Road yeah
maybe we should come back to this one it
is a little bit paint on yeah okay oh
sorry sorry guys I'm having some trouble
here with it I keep hearing myself at
the same time yeah yeah basically I mean
d yeah yeah I'll leave your family sorry
I'm having it's just roll took it okay
ah so we were talking about this thing
else before there wasn't a question we
could start next question it was a
question in the in the G+ possible from
idea who looks a lot like Johnny Depp
and asks whether you can put an action
bar at the bottom and as it's stupid to
have it at the top no fine bold
statement so no by default you can't
control the placement of the action bar
you can go to split mode will be at the
top and bottom when the device is narrow
but you can't actually control where
it's placed you could certainly create
custom control which looks a bit like
an actual barber is at the bottom of
that is your choice as to where it's
stupid or not I only think that's less
important because it's mostly you would
use it for its familiarity so that users
recognize it and know how to use it and
so whether you think it's stupid or not
is one thing is open for discussions
with rich Fulcher and all the design
people who created it but right now it's
such a important and standard element of
your and your toolbox that I would
wouldn't deviate from it unless you have
really good reasons you mind if I say
something yeah oh yeah I'm a Leo by the
way I pictures night and anyway the
reason I said the word i'm sorry is
stupid because I wrote the question
several times and it didn't save I
really have no idea how this happened I
elaborated and explained and every time
i refresh the page the question
disappeared so the last time is history
this one just stayed I don't know why
anyway what I meant by it but was the i
have a galaxy note and it's pretty much
impossible to touch the the action bar
that's on the top and most new apps now
use that action bar and it's very hard
for me to reach there because i can't
hold it with one hand and use the the
buttons up there but if the buttons were
on the bottom like with the split one
it's a lot easier to use the buttons
that are at the bottom because i don't
need to reach all the way to the top
yeah i agree that same phone is getting
really big and but do you know can you
even use it the guy cnet one-handed like
is that possible yes most old apps all
the old apps doing the top from
gingerbread that didn't update
themselves are very easy to use because
all the buttons are hidden in the middie
menu and the menu is normally at the
bottom of the phone so i don't the
Galaxy Note has the menu button unlike
the Nexus and other new phones you can
just hit the menu in the pop-up they pop
at the button so it's very easy yeah
the top is normally just for information
I just look at the top I no need to
touch it yeah it doesn't matter and I
intend to get the note too so it's gonna
be even harder oh ah risk of say you're
holding it wrong kind of quick no I
think in its a general direction of
Android oh you know how lot of devices
have these soft buttons at the bottom
with a phone search generally having
your controls right next to those is
problematic in itself because you can
have missed touches where you're
touching the kind of the system home and
back buttons would rather than the
in-app control so I generally think
separating away from that is good but I
do agree that some of the bigger phones
can be hard and I don't have a good
answer for deliberate actions but I'd
say this is why it's really important to
have swype on tabs as well whenever you
have a tabbed interface as it's a it's
not even funny understand thank you for
this tell me Mike's we joined us Mikey
in real time yes sorry father I actually
had the double whammy of not only
leaving the YouTube video on but not
having the audio in the Hangout because
I normally record my podcast using a
hangout and I had a piped into sound
flower so I was hearing like one perfect
audio just 10 seconds off I did
wonderful I'm glad it sorted out now I'm
sorted yeah yeah sorry guys so just to
explaining how to get basically I mean
the idea is to have one sort of set of
tags in one drop down and kind of
initially it would just be an icon in
the action bar which if you opened it up
that you would see the different
statuses like whether it's downloading
or downloaded or so on which gets you
around the traditional don't want it
manager interface and so we just had a
system antique copper that's created
over we all went quiet for a second so
I've trying to get around the download
manager kind of concept by basically
making the whole thing a set of filters
if you like by adding an extra filter
for download status yeah so my worries
about having them next to each other is
that it's kind of a bit hard to parse
might look
bit complicated could you just have like
one in the drop drop down and 11 like in
line in the control itself in the screen
itself it's a little tricky because down
the bottom we've got a player at the
moment in the design so it's a little
hard to have extra it is just you know
trying to avoid adding my not
necessarily at the bottom but like a row
underneath a second row below the action
bar yeah for like a subsequent filter
you could do I mean trying to avoid it
because we've also got tabs as well
alright if you have a few pager or
something to sort of swype to the
different snakes if you make up tabs
already know yeah i mean that's actually
a kind of separate question because i
would like to have a view pager to tear
between different entities you know
effectively label sort of genres but I
don't know it seems like with tabs that
you want to do it swipe between tabs
yeah definitely yeah and actually have a
list of similar things are like
different views of different data than
the other works really well tabs was
swiping though and Marie try and
children with some feedback as well I am
Marie says blue we can help to drop
downs have no different weights good is
a simple structure if you have a
different logical structure like a grid
view or menu on the top and a drop down
inside it would be easier right grid
view or a menu view on top so he just as
a describe the public entity you have a
list of podcasts and you want to have
different ways to slice that by
downloaded versus downloading yes yeah
the kind of status as well as like
errors and so on so you could quickly
see you know what's actually errored and
and then the genre is basically
okay i just try worries you can make
have any one computer all somehow with
the music players view of having the
genres us but horizontally by like a
viewpager in taps so you have all the
podcasts then you can swipe for drama
once right corner and then at the top
you just have one drop down to filter
right all of the best ages yeah i mean
that that is a possibility i have to
look at that if you could I mean how
would the user discover what's actually
there cuz I like the idea of being
something like Google Plus cool you know
perhaps at the top so they can see which
number was then see on the Tampa and
then the tears would still be yeah yeah
i mean it is possible the other thing
then there is potentially tabs inside
there as well okay we could potentially
get around that but I see what you mean
and then the tabs would potentially be
able to scroll as well like you wouldn't
have to fiddle the Tennessee music
playing on a pond right or the Play
Store is the same similar as well for
the play story yeah so you didn't yeah
you could you also you know you felt
going to an all of you so you can see
all your podcast but then you can swipe
across to go into genres okay no that's
good yeah i mean just um in terms of i
mean is the actual drop down it sounds
like you're guarding me against that
right like it's this kind of understand
erdan double drop down yeah i would I
don't like the sound of it every yeah
actually you'd have to have make your
own custom action or as well yeah okay
okay that's good that's a good overview
thanks alright because my consumer the
end play some sketches on plus and I'm
connotation all right yeah that may
sound like a good plan okay how we do
your questions we do have more questions
and thanks for ears off each I mean was
a Calgary yeah thank you oh let's see if
we do um slightly strange question maybe
just a bit okay one of the developer
features from jelly bean and Ice Cream
Sandwich useful for building
point-of-sale applications it would be
nice if we can provide customer service
and I guess NSC you'd be useful
point-of-sale applications yeah
ah it's very specific question I mean
you can do anything wrong in android
that's what I just gonna skip it I
retain tip that as a lot of people want
to create kind of kiosk type
applications as learning fits that well
you know you don't have the home and
back and recent button to switch out the
application I mean was wondering if that
was the real question and here so i'll
tell you the best way of doing that put
it in a case where it comes at the home
back in recent button yeah include any
functionality you want inside you like
within that magazine recently which
magazine was it and sent weekly
entertainment weekly where they embedded
a android device inside in between the
pages but you could just see the screen
so you didn't really know people often
ask actually how they can lock down
android after you sir controlling inside
house lighting controls whatever it's
going to be and without changing the
firmware the easiest ways to put it in a
custom housing so you can't actually get
to the buttons there was an applet if
you have root access you can hide the
system on if you have root access you
can do an effect on Sophia seeing that
so that could be an option if you doing
a kiosk association for go and play with
the areas we have a moment out about the
AOSP how to customize it and build it
yourself and uh go down that route but
if you have actual devices just change
the housing there in okay onwards anyone
live questions in the room if you go on
a moderator King Nick it's probably it's
not about a question it's just I check
my notes from last week and you
mentioned a guy called Trevor at
Mountain View time is that ring any
bells oh really did you know that was
during our Austrian during Mobile World
Congress I said that he wrote an
application to read the badges and
mobile Congress so okay the Android
stand and scan people's patches using
NFC so he gained quite a bit of NFC
experience at the time he hosts the
developer office hours in amount of your
time zone right eight hours from now 10
p.m. UK time they have their office
hours so chinoy surname is rather John
Trevor Jones yeah he's on
code.google.com / team all of our BIOS
and everything and G Plus pages that
listed it okay we're conscious team
which renders very well on tablet ever
thank you guys nowadays yeah but you can
definitely purse the same question to
the the US time zone and you'll get a
for my expert answer cheers
I think we got one of London's famous
freezes again I'm hero it was that I'm
sorry I name is Paul I appalled I think
everyone else has gone frozen I can see
some people still moving around it's
just the London guys who I think they're
missing a slot so I'm going to drop out
and that should give them a slot to
rejoin in okay
oh my back hello
you
okay dropped out yeah that was nice
hopefully i can now there are other
person we can hear you cool thank you
very much there's a out being very
gracious again this week cheers out no
problem Papa has required so we do have
a question that we've answered before I
am executing an async task inside an
object intended to be part of a library
actually maybe that's a slightly
different variant I'm still how can I
deal with orientation changes because as
we know orientation changes on Android
are going to kill your activity and
restart it if you're in a library it's a
slightly different question I wonder why
yet we play yeah necessarily healthy
activities we up to the person who's
using your library to make sure that
they manage rotation changes in keeping
your state and things are that so if
you're using an async task inside the
librarian you don't know what context
your libraries being used it it's going
to be much harder so I think you can't
really you even have to you have to do
as a service wouldn't you going to say
to the developer that you've got to
include it in their manifest so that the
service can be fired off whenever a
service to be much smaller thing to do
yeah or use a motor or doesn't say
extend an async task later as well
because that will handle the orientation
change for you but I was donating time
certainly I think you've answered the
question yourself inside the question I
don't you Jason tasks inside libraries
when you don't have a context of how the
users can use it my life you'd have to
be very specific to the user on how to
implement your library or they'd be
seeing issues all over the place or full
rotation yeah but I am surprised hasn't
come up earlier actually saying that I
thought been answered before it is a
slightly more interesting slant to the
async task issue okay anything else
coming in earlier duck keep a threat is
only four minutes ago anyone have a
final question my ask for vets
which we just spent four minutes saying
the lights hammer there we go there
Emily we don't know yeah oh damn it
there's a lot of page I'm sure the other
places my questions were answered my
advice has a screamer yes lucky guy
doesn't have free time so have you ever
found out who done it rich would you
just miss that last page so we've
answered all the questions except the
ones on the last page how we have to my
device screen has a resolution of 800 x
480 and an hdmi connector how do I get
full HD resin all apps when i plug it to
full HD monitor with hdmi cable up
connecting it to monitor with apps on
screen around 800 x 480 but films room
full HD ok that's yet by default moment
android gist is narrowing so it will
just do mirror what's on your screen so
you get the same screen resolution on
android except the vs special cakes for
video views which will do something
funky yeah it's gonna be harder overlay
stuff is it burning out of the the hdmi
there's nothing you can know about much
i certainly know api's it was looking at
different ways of detecting when hdmi
cables have been plugged in but he
change was gone through question in
subway says and andrew kiosk and HMI
mirroring be disabled that's why i was
looking into this issue there's no
platform level way of doing it there's a
certain OEMs include api so like
Motorola has an API for detecting the
hdmi state and reacting accordingly and
other people do as well there is a event
broadcast event that happens when HDMI
plug cables plugged in and out but it's
currently hidden for good reasons I
assume so I can't rely on that always
being there yeah so right now so there's
not a dating story how can I get screen
capture from device we have 25 to 30
frames a second to my computer HTA app
or only to another monitor like on
presentations on Google i/o devices
might have hdmi or any other video
connector
into it Google i/o we use HDMI app
there's also the ln8 the ln8 you
pronounce will you know if you want
video content and things it doesn't
necessarily nad wearing they which is a
lie screen it will just be able to share
like a specific content like a file or
something other good things that the new
hardware accelerated emulators I made a
video using one of those quite recently
and it came out very well then good you
know you can watch video you can always
use you in there in the video frame rate
so good so the hardware accelerated
emulators with images provide by in time
and GPU acceleration are very good yeah
I'd say you've even eh ma those two
miles away to Gomes is your best I mean
it's gonna be that the fastest most
responsive one with the highest
resolutions he's like bluestacks maybe
even on your PT and I can't read that
blue specks runs in a window so probably
will have the same problems as say using
the emulator or using a virtual box look
you mean the same problems recording
from a window unless you've got an
application that will do that well and
give you a good quality output you want
it yes script like desktop screen
recording is there's tons of software
absolutely right i'm i'm not sure i'd
not come across any ones I'm I'm
100-percent happy with bugs in a few who
haven't used one on that um what
remedies when we did that scrolling
tricks with the sticky scoring and stuff
just desktop recorder to to every well
oh cool I'll give it a shot and again
yeah the hardware related item your
hardware accelerated emulator it
certainly makes emulator much more
performant and useful for this kind of
thing but yeah the best bet you gonna
get is one my favorite tricks is is in
real device with the show touches turn
on which which can create really good
product it is show touches your tip and
to finish it off Paul ask is anyone
going to join con London in late October
wait one can I one more thing sorry go
ahead I'm sorry and I heard in a news
app called a piggy that google released
the template for building apps but I've
not seen it anywhere like I've searched
google dinner ADT
but it's in your ad tu android developer
tools inside eclipse plugin oh and your
project in there it's a template it's
not being pointed across to IntelliJ at
this point so yeah that's in a heating
right I'm I'm a software engineer but I
only work with the computers only
started working with android now but the
currently my apt looks like see it
doesn't look anything like Java I don't
use threads and stuff like that it
simply looks like C++ so get app it's
created ma are using a coach to write 0
using what Eclipse yes of course so yeah
it's in a catch the environment tools
you can just do follow me I've
downloaded the sum of your sample apps
but the the spaceship one in the snake
hmm these are Oh they've been in since I
stood up the only ones i have access to
her than anything newer let me update
something doesn't do matically when
you're watching a game or i'm making
imperfect making a game yes I you could
look at if you google for Christmas game
called again when done right no no no go
island yeah replica island thanks how
replica island yeah this is a former
teammate of us who an open-sourced game
written it's all written in Java and
yeah yeah oh and so on so that said
they'll help you bootstrap if you want
to your game leaf and all that stuff
they'll be so good go to copy again a
little bit dated but I've already made
several games but they all use a use one
class to make like a loop and the rest
of it look just like the main in C so it
just repeats that pond so all the
threadings and all the advanced stuff
are not available for me if i use it
like this yeah it definitely is a
replica ride in the source code you'll
give you a lot of ways to handle input
and in earth the device ill let me guess
blunt thank you thank you thank you all
very much for joining us on this week's
Android developer of South emea edition
uh we'll catch all that when you stay
thanks guys ty by everyone
how about stuff